( music)
- Hi everyone, and I'm glad
to be in the company of
other language teachers, but the points
that I'm going to talk
about and mention today
don't really have anything
to do with language.
So, hopefully they'll
be useful to everyone.
So, like many of you, when we
first started using Canvas,
I had this huge fear of, like, oh my god,
this is going to be a huge waste of time,
I'm going to have to spend
so much time learning
how to do this, I'm going to
have to spend so much time
putting all my teaching resources on it,
this is a whole new learning process.
So what I'm going to talk
about today, is, like,
things that I did in order to
save time, and cut on time,
and things that I know
students appreciate it,
because not only did it save me time,
but it saved them time as well.
So I'm going to start from the beginning,
and I'm sure you're
familiar with this picture.
This is what we see when we first want to
log in and check Canvas.
And you can see that these
are the tabs for the classes,
and the way to tell one
class from the other
is the color, I don't know about you,
but as far as I'm concerned,
a number of times I clicked
on the wrong box and I found
myself in the wrong class.
And I'm like, no, this is
not at all what I want to do.
And I had to go back a
couple of steps to enter.
An easy way to solve this problem
is if you personalize your class,
and put a picture as to
what each class looks like,
so these are two of the
classes that I'm teaching
this semester, each one has a picture.
It's a lot easier for me to
click on the right picture
when I want to go to the right class.
And also, as far as the
students is concerned,
'cause like you, they have
like four or five tabs
that are only different in color,
but now, when there's a
picture to your class,
they can easily identify it
and access it quite easily.
Another thing that I found useful
and saved me a lot of time,
is using the calendar.
We've heard already a
couple of our presenters
mentioning different
techniques of using Canvas.
Calendar is one of them, it
certainly is not the only one.
This is where calendar is,
if you haven't used it.
And when you click on it,
you can go to the calendar,
and what you can do is for every day,
or for every week, or
multiple times a day,
you can set up different events.
And what I do is I start early,
before the beginning of the semester.
I go to the calendar and I
put in every single test,
or quiz, or a writing assignment,
or grading activity, or even
activities that are not graded
that might be of
importance to the student.
And when you go to the calendar,
when you click on each day,
this is the tab that you're going to get.
What allows you to put
in either an activity,
or an assignment, and the
details, and the link,
and the time, et cetera et cetera.
The other thing that you can
do from the same calendar
is you can have it assigned
to two different classes,
or three different
classes, for that matter.
As a language teacher, I
teach multiple sections,
so this is useful, I don't have
to do the same thing again.
Rather, all I have to
do is change the class
and add it to the calendar of that class.
The other amazing thing, once I'm done,
on the main page of what the students see,
they can see, as you can see right here,
all the times, all the activities
that I've set up in the
calendar, they're all there
nicely arranged
chronologically, so they know
when they have a test and
when they have a quiz.
They don't need to ask me,
I don't need to answer.
Everybody's saving time.
Another nice thing about calendar is that
you can actually synchronize it,
so if you click on this tab over here,
you'll find out that there's an option
that you can add all these
dates to your Google calendar.
Whatever your personal Google calendar is,
you can add, so this
is what you would get.
And if you take the link and
add it to your Google calendar,
all these dates will be added
to your Google calendar.
It's especially helpful for the students,
because they have other
events and other classes
and other stuff that they have to do.
This way they can see everything
on their Google calendar
without having to ask me,
and I don't have to answer.
The other thing that I do that saves me
and the students time,
is I use assignment,
and when I set up assignments,
I give each one of them value
depending on category,
and when I do that, again,
through the magic of Canvas, they can see
on their first page, on the
front page of the class,
they can see exactly
what are the graded items
that they have to go through,
and how much each of them is worth.
Yes, we have a syllabus, and the syllabus
we put all this thing together,
but it's nice for them
through one click, as
soon as they sign in,
they can see all this information
without having to ask me.
The other advice that I have for everyone,
I have been teaching for a while,
and I have developed a
number of teaching resources.
And I found out using Canvas,
that there's always a way
to imbed materials that
you have had from the past,
you don't need to do it
again, all you have to do
is ask someone, or get
the advice of someone.
And there's always a way to
imbed your previous materials.
I have successfully been
able to imbed videos,
other teaching materials
that I've used in the past
from other technological resources.
And again, I teach
elementary, at least I'm
teaching elementary this year, so a lot
of my teaching material came
from different resources.
And I was successful in
imbeding all of them.
And this enables me to use it on the site
for the students as
assignment, or as homework,
but even in the class
it has been quite useful
and quite helpful, and
I didn't have to change
a whole lot of my teaching materials.
So these were just some tips from me
that I hope will save
you some time, and also
save your students some time,
which they will appreciate.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
Any questions?
Yes.
- [Person In Audience] When
you set up the calendar,
do you have to do it every year,
or you can navigate it
like the assignments?
- No, I'm afraid you have
to do it every semester,
because the way I do it
is depending on the date.
That's why you can't
move it from one semester
to the other, yes, I
set it up by the dates
for the quizzes and the tests,
and the written assignments.
- [Person In Audience]
From a student perspective,
oh, sorry.
If I set up the calendar for my course,
from the student perspective, if they have
a number of different courses,
does their calendar then show things
from all the different
courses with different colors?
- Yes, that's exactly-
- So that when they complain
that they can't figure out
how to sync their lives up,
they have a way of doing
that if we've helped them
by putting it on the calendar?
- Yes, exactly.
And yes, so, whatever items there are
on the Canvas calendar,
they will be different
with different colors.
And when you hover the mouse over it,
it will tell you the name of the class.
Like, let's say they're not sure
which class is the pink color.
If you just hover the mouse over it,
it will tell you which class that is.
- [Person In Audience] Thank you.
- Certainly, you're welcome.
- [Person In Audience] Which
Canvas tools do you use
to imbed the examples that you gave here?
For example, do you use assignments,
do you use the quizzes?
- I've been able to imbed
stuff in mostly assignments,
but also in the pages,
and even on the front page
I've been able to imbed stuff.
Absolutely.
You're welcome.
- [Person In Audience] When
you're using the calendar,
is it possible for students to, like,
click on the event and have
it go directly to Canvas
for that assignment?
- Yes, yes, absolutely.
If it is something that will take,
that is linked to an
assignment, or a quiz,
yes, it will take them there
right away, absolutely.
Yep.
- And then you can import, in other words,
if you set up, we just did a
debate, for example, today,
because I use it not only
for my written quizzes.
If the quiz is set up electronically,
you can import from year to year,
and the dates will adjust for you.
So it automatically adjusts beautiful.
You don't have to do it by hand.
But presume you don't
want to put all your tests
on Canvas, so then it depends what you do.
If you have, say, oral
presentations assignment,
then I believe, again, as
long as the date is given.
Like today, we did
orals, and there is a tab
that requires submissions.
So that means, when I import
resources for next year,
the date will adjust for me.
In other words, it will
still be that assignment
on Tuesday, or whatever the new date.
It will automatically adjust, so
yes, you will, depends on what type,
like fellow presentations obviously,
that you have to import by hand,
but other events it will import.
So you don't have to do all of it by hand.
(applause)
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(music)